have you spotted any pirate ships are
you gonna get snippy with us clown
you know actually I think there's a good
restaurant right up here
whoa
that has changed since the last time we
were here
my name is Paul Sturgis I work for Nixon
oil supposed to Ferry out to the rig
from here Dad I think I see it is that
it yep that's her
I'm here to do the inspection
what is it
protection from what huh
hello
anybody
where the hell is everyone
what's going on here
[Music]
what is that what's that looks the black
Beamer
there must be some way off this rig
nothing works I don't think it can take
much more punishment this is just any
shark it's a curse right on not by
nature but by wrath wrath
he's gonna keep getting his revenge
until the sacrifice is made
[Music]
to stop it it's the killing
I have a plan
you will not take my family away from me
kill the monster open your eyes come on
I know a big ass shark when I see one
okay